after six months of hard graft my bad
boys bakery has finally been thrown a
lifeline cafe Nero have agreed to give
our lemon treacle slices a trial for a
week by tomorrow my brigade have got to
have 1100 bait and ready to go
but I've had some devastating news Paul
Wyatt has been working at my Savoy Grill
restaurant for three weeks but I've just
heard he might be back on drugs every
time I look at him I look at I suppose
worse you know reflection on my little
brother so it's like here we go
this guy that got dealt that
dysfunctional card and through no fault
of his own
initially he's found himself in the [ __ ]
however I'm just gonna ask him straight
we can't tolerate that I said I thought
Paul was ready to work but putting him
in a busy kitchen like the Savoy could
have been a mistake what was on the
trolley today Degel Anthony how are you
hey feeling good and you sure you can
manage 50 hours a week I mean you don't
think you're gonna pull back a little
bit and just pace yourself try and see
are you in control and a big question
for me is have you stayed clean
I'm gonna be honest with you because I
heard from inside that you would relapse
you've taken something no you haven't
so that slice I want to support Paul but
I know from personal experience
Haddix don't always tell the truth deep
down inside you know he's be suffering
but he's got to go through that turn
around
only he can do it and there's been a
void in his life so he may be back in
prison the rookies have been put to work
under Tesla's expert guidance well now
it's a fully fledged production kitchen
it's turned into a business now
handle with care he's tricky he's tricky
now though only makes you huh David I've
never seen your hand so steady pretty
good indeed yeah really good you have
nozzle nice and clean every last one of
these slices has got to be perfect trust
me I mean Katherine here I'll be the
first on the phone if any sent back or
any issues complaints problems they'll
be on my case with her [ __ ] harpy
every single slice has got to be checked
for nuts and bolts on the way out I'm
hoping our own metal detector might
speed things up I hit me baby let's go
especially with tests rather controls it
doesn't get any better than this is it
and packaged literally hours after it
was cooked and never get any fresh on
this weight - so now you go too fast you
know slow down but Jesus under than I'd
be saying that to you six months we go
slow down
[ __ ] happens
boys that
maybe I spoke too soon the wine but it's
a false alarm
Tesla's too fast for his own good okay
chess hit me yeah let's go back in back
in business the bad boys bakeries first
major order is going to be sold in 11
cafe narrow stores across southwest
London I'll see you tomorrow
just remember by the time you wake up
tomorrow morning you had the product
would be in caffeine air oh yeah well
done where the what's that mean I don't
want it to just be that bam bam make on
one little TV program and that's it you
know I mean I won't have a people to be
able to arm get this feeling that we're
getting right now it's been a long time
you know since I felt pride girl I
bought myself anyway you know everyday
come down here and I produce something
good you know I feel this is it I mean I
don't know I mean I'm quite nervous and
DJ that's it it's out of our hands it's
all down to the British public [ __ ]
there we go
you're right I witnessed my younger
brother triumph fail to go clean
countless times so spoken to my
restaurant manager at the Savoy Grill
and decided to give Paul a chance this
course has made me happy inside makes me
want to get up for the morning makes me
want to strive to be someone to do
something